SOME RYLAN PICKS ARE SET TO
KICK OFF IN 6 WEEKS.
TIME ASSISTANCE BY GROWING
CALLS TO CANCEL THE GAMES AMID
A DEVASTATING 4TH WAVE OF THE
PANDEMIC.
MEANWHILE JAPAN IS ALSO DEALING
WITH A GROWING EPIDEMIC OF
LONELINESS.
IT IS A CRISIS THAT IS ONLY
MAGNIFIED BY THE COVID PANDEMIC.
WE ARE JOINED YEAST BY CNN IN
TOKYO WITH MORE ON THIS.
ONE MORE CAN YOU TELL US?
>> ROBIN, IT'S A VERY SAD
SITUATION.
EARLIER THIS YEAR JAPAN
APPOINTED A MINISTER OF
LONELINESS TO TACKLE THE
COUNTRY'S MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS,
A SEEMINGLY MONUMENTAL TASK.
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC HIT
JAPAN HAS HAD A SERIOUS PROBLEM
WITH LONELINESS, ISOLATION AND
SUICIDE.
THESE ARE ISSUES AFFECTING THE
ENTIRE POPULATION, BUT IN
DIFFERENT WAYS.
OREN >> FOR THE 3RD TIME THIS
WEEK, HE AND HIS TEAM ENTER A
HOME TO CLEAN.
A SIMPLE JOB, THAT NOTHING
ABOUT IT IS EASY.
>> HE PROBABLY DIED HERE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG, THE BODY
FLUID HAS SOAKED IN.
BUT I THINK PROBABLY HEAR.
>> HE'S BEEN IN THE CLEANING
BUSINESS FOR ABOUT 13 YEARS.
BUT RECENTLY, HE SAYS CLEANING
UP AFTER LONELY DEATHS WHERE
PEOPLE DIE ALONE AND REMAIN
UNDISCOVERED FOR LONG PERIODS
OF TIME, HAS SADLY TURNED INTO
BIG BUSINESS.
>> WE DO THIS KIND OF WORK
EVERY DAY.
THIS IS A SCENE WE ALWAYS
WITNESS.
WE COULD SEE HIS LIFE IS
GETTING ROUGH AND THAT HE IS
ISSUING AN SOS.
THIS IS AN ORDINARY SCENE FOR
US.
>> THE 79 YEAR OLD MAN WHO
LIVED HERE DIED ALONE.
THE CAUSE OF DEATH IS UNKNOWN.
POLICE SAY HIS BODY WAS FOUND
ABOUT A MONTH AFTER HE DIED.
YAKUTSK IN THROUGH THIS
APARTMENT, IT IS OF TIME HAS
STOOD STILL.
THERE'S STILL FOOD AND DRINKS
ON THE COUNTER.
MAIL ON THE FLOOR, IF YOU TAKE
A LOOK AROUND THIS APARTMENT
THERE IS GARBAGE AND CLOTHES
SCATTERED EVERYWHERE.
IT IS A HEARTBREAKING SCENE.
IT IS ALL TOO COMMON HERE IN
JAPAN.
>> HE'S AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR
AT THIS UNIVERSITY WHO STUDIES
LONELINESS.
WHILE SHE SAYS JAPAN'S AGING
POPULATION IS THAT GREAT RISK
OF ISOLATION, IT IS ACTUALLY
THE YOUNG THAT SUFFER MOST.
HER RESEARCH ANALYZING THE
PUBLIC'S MENTAL HEALTH FOUND
40% OF THE ENTIRE JAPANESE
POPULATION FEELS LONELINESS.
FOR THOSE UNDER 40, THAT NUMBER
IS 50%.
>> THERE ARE HIGH SUICIDAL
IDEATION.
THEY WANT TO KILL THEMSELVES
VERY OFTEN.
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'RE USELESS,
THAT THEY HAVE NO MEANING IN
LIFE.
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL EFFECT OF
LONELINESS ON INDIVIDUALS IS
VERY HIGH.
>> A PSYCHOLOGICAL EFFECT
LIKELY IMPACTING MORE PEOPLE AS
A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC.
IN 2020, FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
11 YEARS, THE SUICIDE RATE IN
JAPAN INCREASED FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR AND CHANGED.
>> WE TYPICALLY HAPPENS DURING
THE ECONOMY CRISIS, THE MIDDLE
AGED MEN DIED BY SUICIDE.
FOR NOW IT'S THE YOUNG ONES.
SOMETHING IS GOING ON.
>> AND THE NUMBERS SHOW IT IS
GETTING WORSE.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
POLICE AGENCY, THE SUICIDE RATE
IN THE MONTH OF APRIL INCREASED
MORE THAN 19% COMPARED TO LAST
APRIL, WHILE THE PANDEMIC HAS
CLAIMED MORE THAN 10,000 LIVES
IN JAPAN DURING THAT TIME, MORE
THAN 23,000 PEOPLE HAVE TAKEN
THEIR OWN LIVES.
FOR THIS PERSON, THOSE NUMBERS
ARE PERSONAL.
SHE EXPERIENCED LONELINESS,
DEPRESSION AND CONTEMPLATED
SUICIDE WHEN SHE WAS 30 YEARS
OLD.
SHORTLY AFTER GIVING BIRTH TO
HER FIRST CHILD.
>> I WANTED TO DISAPPEAR.
I DID NOT KNOW HOW TO HANDLE MY
FEELINGS, AND IT WAS TOO
PAINFUL TO THINK ABOUT WHAT TO
DO.
>> ABOUT A DECADE LATER, SHE
STUDIED PSYCHOLOGY AND IS A
COUNSELOR, A 24-HOUR CHAT
SERVICE FOR SOMEONE WHO JUST
NEEDS TO LISTEN.
SHE INTERACTS WITH 45 PEOPLE
TODAY.
SHE USES HER OWN STRUGGLE WITH
LONELINESS TO HELP OTHERS.
>> I WANT TO SAY THAT YOU ARE
NOT SO ALONE.
WE SERIOUSLY WANT TO LISTEN TO
YOUR STORY.
VOICING YOUR CONCERN IS NEVER A
BAD THING.
IT DOES NOT MEAN THAT YOU ARE
RUNNING AWAY FROM THE PROBLEM
OR YOU ARE WEAK.
>> EXPERTS SAY ABOUT 30,000
PEOPLE HERE IN JAPAN DIE LONELY
DEATHS EACH YEAR.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, THIS IS THE
RESULT.
CLEANERS HAVE TO COME IN AND
PICK UP THE PIECES OF A LIFE
LOST.
>> I CANNOT GET USED TO THIS.
TIME HAS STOPPED HERE.
I COULD FEEL WE KIND OF LIFE HE
WAS HAVING HERE RIGHT AWAY.
HONESTLY SPEAKING, MY HEART
ACHES.
>> IN TERMS OF JAPAN'S NEW
MINISTER OF LONELINESS, HE SAYS
HIS FIRST TASK IS TO IDENTIFY
THOSE WHO ARE ISOLATED, LONELY
AND AT RISK OF BEING CUT OFF
FROM SOCIETY.
HE ALSO PLANS TO PROMOTE
ACTIVITIES TO PROTECT THE TIES
BETWEEN PEOPLE.
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT JAPAN IS
NOT THE FIRST COUNTRY TO
APPOINT A MINISTER OF
LONELINESS.
THE UNITED KINGDOM DID SO IN
2018, LARGELY TO FOCUS ON THE
LONELINESS ENDURED BY THE
ELDERLY.
OF COURSE, ROBIN, THE ISSUE IS
SERIOUSLY IMPACTING BOYS AND
GIRLS, MEN AND WOMEN OF ALL
AGES HERE IN JAPAN.
>> REALLY IMPORTANT POWERFUL
PIECE.
THANKS FOR BRINGING IT TO US.
, BLAKE ESSIG.
AS HE MENTIONS, SOCIAL
ISOLATION AND SUICIDE ARE NOT
UNIQUE TO JAPAN.
FOR SUPPORT, A WORLDWIDE
DIRECTORY OF RESOURCES AND
INTERNATIONAL HOTLINE PROVIDED
BY THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION FOR SUIC